[Music]
all right we have to talk about the
so-called Muslim band today before I say
anything else I want to be absolutely
100% crystal-clear on one simple fact I
am completely and fervently against any
ban on immigrants based solely on their
religion whatever that religion may be I
will always judge people as individuals
not as the collective and I certainly
don't plan on stopping that now is this
fight over refugees and immigration is
just heating up within any group there
are subgroups of people and often it's
these very subgroups that contain the
most vulnerable populations such as free
thinkers gays and atheists so just so
the trolls get it absolutely right
I Dave Rubin and 100% against any
blanket ban which targets all Muslim
people and I would feel exactly the same
way if it was targeting any other
religion okay so we know that this
refugee issue is one of the topics where
no matter what anyone says and
definitely in my case I'm going to get
hate from both the extreme left and the
extreme right actually the more hate
that I get from both sides the more I
realize that I'm doing the right thing
because you want honesty and logic are
completely lost on those who stay on the
dogmatic fringes so before I share my
thoughts I thought it would be important
that we actually separate some facts
from fiction and discuss what's actually
in Trump's executive order I've got the
whole text of the order right here and
yeah I actually read the whole thing
unlike most of the people screaming
about it online okay so despite what the
hashtag on Twitter might tell you this
is not a Muslim ban first off the word
Muslim isn't in the text of the order
not even once and you'd think that if
you were exclusively trying to ban
people of one religion from entering the
country
you'd have to cite which religion you're
talking about secondly and perhaps more
importantly the ban doesn't include any
of the five most populous Muslim
countries Indonesia India Pakistan
Bangladesh and I
gee Rhea so if this was exclusively a
Muslim ban it does stand to reason it
would include these nations which add up
to roughly 750 million people so if it's
a Muslim ban its excluding more than
half of the Muslims in the world this
doesn't mean that there aren't some
valid questions about the list of
countries which are banned as well as
some glaring omissions in this executive
order the seven countries listed in the
order are Syria Libya Sudan Iran Yemen
Somalia and Iraq all of these countries
are involved in heavy sectarian violence
some of which is a direct result of
American intervention without question
to be clear though no major terrorist
attack has happened on American soil
from anyone from these seven countries
currently on the banned list at the same
time there are emissions on the list
most notably Saudi Arabia which 19 of
the 21 9/11 hijackers were from the
argument I've heard on this is that the
ban applies to current conflict zones
and as odious as the Saudi government
may be the country is in a war zone I
don't really see how this is related to
whether extremists are coming out of the
country actually we know they have in
the past and they continue to do so but
that seems to be the argument being made
there are also many questions as to
whether Trump's business ties in
countries like Turkey and Saudi Arabia
or at least part of the reason that they
were left off the list we know for a
fact that Turkey is letting Isis
fighters into Europe through its borders
and we know that Saudi Arabia is home to
the world's most fervent strain of Sunni
Wahhabi ISM so a quick recap so far we
have a ban on nationals from countries
which are currently hotbeds for
terrorism though the list is incomplete
at best and arbitrary or ill-conceived
at worst
up next is whether this is an actual ban
or not from reading the document and
again I read it as well as analysis from
other sources that I generally trust
there is no way that this order at the
moment as it is written right now is
some kind of permanent ban on people
from the countries listed it's a 90 day
ban on people from those
in countries and a total temporary stop
of our refugee admission system for a
hundred twenty days so the vetting
system and other processes can be
reviewed the one exception to this
temporary stop is for Syrian refugees
who are being banned indefinitely
perhaps this will lead to Trump trying
to actually ban all foreign nationals
from these countries or even expanding
it to other countries but at the moment
it is a temporary ban while we figure
out what's going on at our borders
simply put whether you like it or not
this is one of the promises the Trump
made during the campaign season if at
the end of 120 days we have a stronger
vetting process not based on blanket
bigotry but rather on informed decisions
about each person individually then we
can finally start to have an honest
discussion about how many refugees we
can or should let in on the extremes we
now have people calling for totally open
borders which is national suicide and we
also have other people calling for zero
immigration which is the antithesis of
what America stands for another
important piece of the order is the
deference that's being given to
religious minorities who are under
persecution I find the anger against
this quite confusing the left is
supposed to be for minorities but in
this case giving priority to use Edie's
Kurds Christians and others who are
being wiped out as we speak if somehow
being flipped as if this is supposedly
anti-muslim the truth is that these
religious minorities are the most
vulnerable communities in the entire
Middle East it doesn't matter if you're
a believer or a non-believer to
understand that protecting the most
at-risk is the right thing to do an
interesting point to add here is that
the Obama administration led in 12,000
Muslims from Syria in 2016 but only a
hundred Christian refugees I don't know
the reasoning behind this policy but
where was the outrage when Obama left
Christians behind if this current
outrage is really about protecting
minorities who are in harm's way the
order also limits the amount of refugees
to 50,000 per year which is basically in
line with where we've been at over the
past 15 years or so for example in 2003
2006 into
seven we admitted less than fifty
thousand refugees per year under george
w bush obama bumped that up a bit to
seventy thousand people in the last two
years of his administration but in the
previous three years before that he was
right around that fifty thousand mark as
well without getting too lost in the
numbers here the point is that trumps
proposal isn't far off of previous
administrations especially if you remove
the little bump under the last two years
of obama of course you can argue that
american action or inaction in syria has
led to many of these refugees in the
first place so again where was the
outrage when we were dropping bombs not
just temporarily limiting refugees of
course the last few years also coincide
with a jump in worldwide jihad
especially in countries which have taken
in many refugees i think if you could
ask the people of germany france and
belgium if they might rethink some of
their immigration policies over the past
few years there would probably be a
resounding yes
these countries now have to deal with
homegrown terror as well as the influx
of refugees which has created a new set
of problems both economically and
culturally none of this is a reason not
collect sensible amounts of properly
vetted refugees in but it does lend
credence to a temporary pause while we
figure out if our vetting system is
effective and sensible the rollout of
this order was no doubt absolutely
chaotic and confusing but i'm not sure
if any real change to our system could
be done without a certain amount of
chaos and confusion especially because
of a media that thrives on emotion over
fact finally there also seems to be some
confusion as to whether people who
currently reside in the united states
with green cards from these seven
countries would be able to come back to
the country after leaving at first it
sounds like they wouldn't have been
allowed to get back in then it sounded
like they could get back in and now it
sounds like it'll be done on a
case-by-case basis for example my friend
and former guest faisal saitama Tarr who
is a refugee from iraq who now lives in
america and has devoted his life to
fighting Islamism and for secularism
could possibly be locked out of the
country if he was to go do a speaking
gig in Canada with my friend and former
guest alyre is be a Muslim reformer
himself this portion of the order still
seems to be in flux which is evidence of
an unprepared rollout of course this is
2017 and unfortunately facts seem to
take a backseat to fiction and hysteria
at every turn so some protesters are
protesting without really knowing what's
going on at all New York Senator Chuck
Schumer is crying and talking about a
Muslim ban when he must know full well
that that isn't what this is
people are now either drinking more
Starbucks or boycotting Starbucks
because Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
said he would hire 10,000 refugees Elan
musk who publicly offered on Twitter to
take people's concerns directly to Trump
is being attacked by people as if he is
enabling a Nazi as I predicted a few
weeks ago misguided outrage is taking
the place of real discussion so when
politician scream about a Muslim ban
which this is not it feeds the fire to
Trump to do whatever he wants because no
matter what he does he knows they are
going to be outraged this is why they're
aggressive less than the trumpian right
or a match made in hell for each other
we have one side which refuses to debate
Islamism and immigration honestly and
another side that will be all too happy
to circumvent our intended legislative
process with the stroke of a pen if you
value liberty over authoritarianism then
either one of these positions is tenable
in an effort to make sense of some of
the madness surrounding this executive
order I have a few interesting
conversations planned for this week and
I also want to share two articles by
people I truly respect though they are
often at opposite ends of the political
spectrum below you can find links to an
article ben shapiro wrote about the
executive water as well as a blog post
by sam harris in addition to those
sources in case you missed it i did a
live stream with faisal yesterday who is
directly affected by this order and you
can find a link to that below as well
and finally my guest this week is no
stranger to controversy himself and also
someone who often finds himself in the
crosshairs of people on both extremes
glenn beck will be joining me in studio
today to discuss refugees trumpism the
modern
served a movement online media and more
I agree with Glenn on some issues and I
disagree with him on some others but I
generally find him to be willing to have
the hard conversations which right now
we need more than ever
[Music]
you
[Music]